every person here grabs this anytime
that there is a commercial yet eighty
billion dollars is spent by the biggest
brands in the world to make 30-second
videos of a jeep going up a hill or some
guy grabbing a beer or some lady with a
baby using some oil eighty billion
dollars it is completely not practical
it is broken and it is the reason that
95 percent of the fortune 500 biggest
brands in the world have declined in
market share over the last two years
here's what matters to everybody in this
room all that money all that money is
coming into our ecosystem once they
start calibrating how bad it actually is
when coca-cola and BMW and the biggest
buy BM start taking that money from page
147 of Sports Illustrated and from a
commercial of guiding light and they
take those dollars and they put them
into Facebook and Instagram the price of
our attention is going to go through the
roof
so I sit here today and plea and I play
that if you are not activating your
marketing in that ecosystem you are
going to miss the golden era of Facebook
marketing and you will regret it and
people run around here there are people
in this room that run around here with
an opinion on Facebook marketing and
they've never deployed a single ad on it
there are people here that run around
and have opinions on Instagram marketing
and have never deployed a single penny
on it period
you